right now we're in Vienna Austria and we
are going to the Apple store this apples
are just opened probably like a week ago
and the first Apple store in Austria so
this is really really exciting like so
close I can feel it
I've heard such esteem oh why are you
going to Vienna this is why we're gonna
go in it's like I've never seen a before
my heart
[Music]
there are a lot of people in there yes
of course I'm gonna get a picture
I want like 500 people who photoshoot
okay
[Music]
we're gonna go in this is a really
really big deal because there's never
been an Apple store an Oscar before so
this is the first one this is actually
the five hundred and first a pasar that
Apple has open kitchen I learned you
just hold it it's just gonna hold it
[Music]
here's a friend we have to win our
friend cement a new friend Daniel we met
him at comprised and he works here at
the Alcazar
first let's take a look at the drone
right now we're inside could not be a
more exciting this is the first floor
we're gonna head up to the second one
after you for that why are you here go
ahead I'm here this is actually an 8k
screen so there's only two of these
screens and one is in Austria and the
other one is the main Cupertino campus
here it is 8k I think it's bad for your
eyes I'm sitting very close
[Applause]
[Music]
the chicken once were me
you guys all know what that is it's okay
this
I think anybody uses it anymore except
me and Jenna
she could look out the window from the
second floor here's the view
hi how did you find us I mean surprise
with the Apple store yeah okay where
else did you guys expect to find me here
at the Apple store I'm so excited
Congrats on the new Apple store this is
very exciting
it is so amazing it's our first ever saw
in Austria and it opened I guess last
week yeah yeah it is amazing it's nice
we just got inside info
we're not sure if this is a homicide
true but it's rumored that these trees
are important there's really not much
new construction here this used to be an
oldest free building since they went
bankrupt just gonna have a bought it and
then they remodeled it and now it's the
dreams like I don't know what to do now
maybe I buy something so sure you need
anything yes I do so because I plan on
coming back when it's not freezing so
that I can be here do you need that
tell you what you don't need that was a
mistake that I made where did I buy that
all that builds on the story
yep so self checkout can only be used in
Apple stores within your home country no
it's real this is a real wall that's
really you want to eat okay
so I think I've completely exhausted
every single thing that I can do here so
I think it's officially time to move on
but if you think I'm gonna stop filming
until I actually leave this building
you're crazy cuz I'm not downstairs let
me be it back downstairs beautiful
but I'm wearing my favorite Apple watch
so like if I buy another one it snuck
into my favorite so I think I made one
purchase I'm satisfied with it now we
can leave
another fun fact that I read online is
they have over 150 employees and they
speak over 44 languages pretty
impressive because I can barely speak
one
so now we're gonna them to zoo and this
is one of the oldest zoos in the world
the oldest zoo and we're gonna take the
subway now where I'm from in Los Angeles
our public transportation is awful
that's right here
everything is beautiful
[Music]
which one is still this one this one
that's a spill isn't responding it's
crazy because it our Starbucks like
everything is to go but they actually
have real plates that you can eat here
there's places John students you can sit
[Music]
this is your subway yeah yeah beautiful
okay cuz you go into a subway in New
York and it's like a trash bin this is a
beautiful pizza rat yeah yeah we're at
the mall right now this is so nice light
[Music]
so does looking online I download the
PDF map and there is a lot to see here I
don't think we're gonna be able to see
it all because it closes in like two
hours so we're gonna see some X you can
see some animal happy holidays here too
yeah pandas elephants giraffes
[Music]
screw the dragon heart am I saying that
right direction
and did I get up here Oh or off me
up
so not drafyn oh my goodness this is so
cool
[Music]
inside the Panda area I don't see do you
see how I don't see it either here papa
Oh outside but I can't
Chito is very close so now this feeding
happening over here it looks like
there's penguins and seals and polar
bears
[Music]
it seems so many amazing animals but now
we're heading into the rainforest area
system anisotropic oh that's Thank You
minute be 80%
so if you can't tell the humidity here
is crazy and everything's gettin steamed
up
Oh oh my god we are actually flying
around
oh my god this is really scary
yeah I think - - it's so humid into the
elephant area and it is the worst smell
I've ever smelled in my life this is
disgusting
do you think they're saying the same
about you I think you didn't say that
[Music]
really definitely definitely
it's pintung styler station we've been
working on our German clearly not going
so well stand out both shooting I forgot
how to say it again to flush the castle
the costume simply merciless we're going
there yeah super excited about it
this pathway is so beautiful I love it
[Music]
to be so great to fly drones the drone
laws in Austria are extremely strict I
was reading some article they're talking
about you could get like six months in
jail and like you know what I gotta
leave the drone at home I don't want to
be stuck in Austria in jail this
actually looks like a college campus
this is crazy we're on the other side
now of the castle we just were this
place is massive we just call them uber
so nuber is coming to pick us up at the
castle I also just dropped my camera so
if it's not working that's why
do you guys remember when we were in
Germany it was two summers ago and a
song was all we played it was on the top
hits at the time what did you say it
music in Tom the one who is always loved
what a hit
we should go quick okay they close at
six o'clock we're finding something to
wear home on the plane because all the
stuff that we have now is dirty so are
these like is this like a popular brand
here what is this called naked town make
it down I'm gonna be super comfy and
super toasty on the fly you know this is
where we leave you where we started back
at the Apple store again time to go home
and pack and we have an extremely
extremely long flight tomorrow because
we have a layover in London and then 11
plus hours from London back to Los
Angeles thank you guys for watching I'll
see you in my next video bye and thank
you so much Austria for an incredible
time and thank you to our new tour guide
[Music]